how can we support those on strike
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV a
movie channel
[Music]
there are a lot of people in Hollywood
right now that are already feeling the
financial squeeze following the strikes
of The Writers Guild of America and
sag-aftra the Screen Actors Guild now
I'm not just talking about the writers
and the actors I'm actually talking
about the wider industry there are
people in hundreds of different fields
that really rely on the TV and movie
industry for their livelihoods and I've
tried to find a charity that supports
the wider entertainment Community not
just the writers or the actors so
Sidetrack will be supporting the
entertainment Community Fund this fund
has been in existence since 1882 it
actually used to be called the actors
fund it is a fund that actually supports
helping people in the entertainment
industry find affordable housing
retirement funds and health care and
support etc etc but they also have an
emergency fund it's that emergency fund
that I will be donating to and I'm going
to ask you to as well since the
Sidetrack channel was able to monetize
I've been able to give a small portion
of the money we generate each month or
two charity we've already given over two
thousand pounds to charity in that time
and during the strikes we're going to be
giving it to the entertainment Community
Fund there's a link in the description
to the fund so you can go and have a
look at the work they do and if you want
to also show your support to the
entertainment industry I would suggest
that that is one of the best places to
go and give your money
but why because it isn't just about the
actors that you know their name of
obviously Tom Cruise is not going to be
having any financial burden during this
he is not going to have to start
switching off lights or you know maybe
like close one of his many pools he's
not going to have to do that
all of the actors that pretty much you
know their names aren't going to have to
do that but it's not about those it's
about the 90 of the actors you've never
heard of it's about all the writers that
work day in day out on the shows you
love that you've never heard of it's
about the guys that do the lighting it's
about the guys that do the sound it's
about the guys that serve the sandwiches
at lunchtime it's about the wide
entertainment industry that is suffering
now we want the strike to end as quickly
as possible from a selfish point of view
it's because I want shows like Stargate
to damn get announced I want the new
Babylon 5 reboot I want great movies I
want great television
I want Hollywood to be the heart of the
entertainment industry around the world
because for me I think they just have
the best product I know that people like
Amazon are looking to make Productions
all over the world and that's a good
thing too but we still want Hollywood to
be at its heart
and if we all want that we need to
support the people on the picket lines
we need to make sure that the actors
writers and everybody else can Outlast
the studios because the Studios have a
plan
they want to starve out these actors
they want to starve out the writers and
they want to starve out everybody else
in the entertainment industry
this has become a war of attrition and
the only way to help them is by giving
them some money the Studios have our
money now are there other ways other
than giving to a fund like this that you
can't help well some people are
basically turning off their um
subscriptions to things like the
streamer services and they're making it
very clear to Netflix when they do that
and everybody else that the reason for
the cancellation is to support the
actors and the writers out on the picket
lines I personally I'm not going to be
doing that and currently the writer's
Guild except for these unions are not
asking you to do that either
but it is an option and that is a
personal choice if you want to make it
and I would actually argue it's not a
bad way to do it because if it starts
affecting the studios Pockets because as
we say it's a war of attrition and we
can give money to the actors the writers
everybody else in the entertainment
industry and we can take money away from
the studios one suggestion was that oh
should we boycott our Cinemas I wouldn't
do that in fact go to the cinema go in
your droves because yes okay the studios
do profit from Cinema releases
put this wider entertainment industry
also profits our Cinemas are already
struggling they were battered throughout
covid we have one of our Major Cinema
Studio chains go under just a couple of
weeks ago here in the UK and the other
ones aren't doing well either this is
about the kids serving you popcorn
behind the counter this is about all of
the people that work there as well as
all of the people that work in the head
offices of these companies
yes okay you're giving money to the
studios but you're also giving money to
The Wider entertainment industry and
that's not a bad thing
so there's a link in the description for
the entertainment Community Fund if it's
a charity that you like the look of then
please give some money and see if you
can help the entertainment industry
what else can we do to help the
entertainment industry though I'd love
to know your ideas again in the comments
and tell me exactly what you think
once the strikes are done I also would
love to know what other Charities that
you know and that are important to you
that you would like us to be able to
donate to I want to really use this
platform that we've got here to help as
many people as we can it's great that
I'm able to give a little bit of money
each month but if we can give a little
bit of money to actually you guys the
site Trekkers think is important then
that's even better
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification you know what to do but
more importantly go on Twitter go on
Instagram go on wherever start following
your favorite actors and start
retweeting their tweets about the strike
Etc show them your support make sure
that they know you're here for them but
also show the studios who we support
as always guys please stay safe and I'll
see you next time
thank you
[Music]